so when somebody says
define yourself
i think of myself as somebody who is
community engaged and about helping make
things better around them it sounds i
suppose a little
altruistic but it's it's the way i think
of myself
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
have you ever played video games or
heard of the xbox well today we're going
to be talking to the person who founded
the xbox meet robiebach author speaker
and civic engineer xbox llc
robbie is best known for founding and
leading the team that created the xbox
today he is an entertaining storyteller
and catalyzing voice who writes books
and speaks to audiences on leadership
creativity strategy and civic issues
during his 22 years at microsoft robbie
worked in various marketing and business
management roles including supporting
the successful launch and expansion of
microsoft office and leading the
creation and development of the xbox
business
then as microsoft's president of the
entertainment and devices division he
was responsible for the company's
worldwide gaming music video phone and
retail sales
businesses until he retired in 2010
the wilkes insurrection is his first
novel for more information you can visit
the website
robbie bach welcome to 20 minute leaders
it is such an honor thank you for being
here thanks for having me on michael
good it's good to see you
robbie i'm really really excited to talk
about so many different things
you
for 22 years you were with microsoft as
president of entertainment and services
worldwide
one of the founding members of the xbox
team and and seeing it through and i
cannot wait to hear about this
experience and working with bill gates
and steve ballmer
but then turned to a civic engineer and
author and a speaker and a novelist and
a storyteller and so i'm really excited
to talk also about creativity and how
that goes back to your time at microsoft
and and how that what that means you
know about you and and and what sort of
your journey is like and how you
perceive you know your professional and
personal journey yourself and so it's
going to be a really fun conversation
robbie thank you very very much for
being here
how do you define yourself robbie
well
you know i i think of myself as somebody
who
has always
been committed to
um
community and civics and what's going on
in the in the environment around me
and
and i
of course i went and did a what you
would think of as a traditional
professional career i went to business
school i went to work at microsoft i i
did all those things
but i've always
felt our calling back to what's going on
in our community in civics and and
and how we make things better around us
every day and even when i was at
microsoft i felt like there were things
i was able to do there that that helped
make that happen so
i've that's been a constant in my life
for a long long time so when somebody
says
define yourself
um i think of myself as somebody who is
community engaged and about helping make
things better around them it sounds like
i suppose a little
altruistic but it's it's the way i think
of myself
well i'm excited to to un unravel that
piece you know as we also talk about
your experiences you know in the in the
professional world and what you learned
there take me back to microsoft so you
know the obvious question the founding
of xbox and leading the team and working
with with bill gates and steve ballmer
a lot to unpack but
how did it all start
well this this all got started
um really through a series of of teams
that were exploring whether we should be
entering the video game space and they
were doing that on their own
uh with no guidance from anyone frankly
um and that's often how these things get
started
uh we were at an executive staff retreat
bill discovered that this work was going
on he decided it was important to go
meet with them because of what sony was
doing with playstation 2.
um from that bill said hey i think
there's a technical approach here that
works
uh he asked steve ballmer who then asked
me and a guy named rick thompson to go
figure out whether there was a business
model there
and at the end of that year so that was
about a seven month period at the end of
that year they approved xbox we had 20
people
and we had 18 months and we said go
now what what what as you positioned
yourself to to lead this team and you're
you're going and you're saying okay we
have 18 months
how do you even measure yourself what is
it what is sort of the you know the kpi
that you set for this console that is
going to be you know later on taking
over the world by storm
well
you'll laugh at this
i
and i speak about this all the time
you'd think at that point we'd have this
detailed strategy with everything sort
of orchestrated and figured out but the
fact of the matter is we kind of had two
roughly what i'll call kpis one was step
before the holiday of 2001.
so that's our 18 month target got a ship
by then otherwise we're irrelevant and
two the explosions have to look really
great
and
everything else was just get it done
wow and you know
it's not the right way to run a railroad
it's not the right way to run a business
uh but when you're going from 20 people
to 2 000 people in 18 months
um you just won hard and fast and and
that's what
we have to we have to pause on on this
exact moment
going from 20 people to 2 000 people and
now i'm looking at this from a
leadership perspective what is that like
what what what is it like to grow from
you know what is it 100x
yeah i can't even do the math it was
um
truthfully it was the worst 18 months of
my professional life
wow um the job completely consumed me
um it consumed the team
uh we were working
you know 18 hours a day
and
i was sort of
you know you struggled with your
personal life you struggle with your
family
and every day was sort of a fire fight
against the challenges of that day
and not being strategy-led was super
hard
and you know somehow through sheer will
we got to the end and shipped the
product but it's not the right way to do
it and clearly
uh i failed i was the leader of that
team and there was an element of failure
there for sure and you know i've
reflected on that and
when we went to the second version of
xbox we did it completely differently
wow
so can you go into that a little bit
more detail so
what what changed from a leadership
perspective that you learned from the
first version to the second version that
either made you a better leader or a
better product
yeah i think well the fundamental we
made two fundamental changes one we
decided that we had to be strategy led
and so we stepped back and said what's
the strategy
for the second version of xbox and we
created this thing called the 3p
framework which is something i use still
to this day and all the strategy work
that i do
and it basically says in three pages
tell me the purpose of the project one
sentence
the five principles you're going to use
to manage and operate the team and the
five priorities you're going to pursue
to be successful
purpose principles priorities three
pages now
it turns out you think that's easy
writing that in three pages turns out to
be incredibly difficult
and
but we we struggled through that and got
it done and it did two things for us
one
um by doing strategy led we were able to
get the team organized and enabled
decisions to be made much further down
in the organization that was super
important and the second thing it did
the principles really helped us organize
the culture of the group
uh the first version of xbox had no xbox
culture it was uh a mosh pit of cultures
from all the different places we hired
people
it was super difficult to manage and was
just messy uh the second version
um we had team xbox
and that team was incredibly talented
individually
but powerful as a group and uh made the
second version i worked you know frankly
just as hard on the second version as it
did on the first version
but xbox 360 was a joy to build
um the original xbox was a complete pain
in the butt and really hard
but robbie was it was there even hope to
be able to
to design the first xbox with the same
mentality because i'm thinking of it
like as a startup and you're building
this mvp you're just you're figuring out
what the hell does it mean to even build
a video game console are you a were you
looking back would it have been possible
to create a team xbox for version one
without experimenting and going through
the burning of these 18 months
you know
i've thought about that a lot and i've
tried to give myself a pass as a leader
but ultimately i i really can't look
it was easier to have xbox 360 be more
organized there's no question about that
but if we had done just a few simple
fundamentals the first time around
if we had
created just the simplest of outlines of
a strategy if we'd had a little bit of
discussion about how we wanted to work
together as a team
um we could have we could have made that
so much easier now the difficulties of
the technology and getting everything
done on time and all those kinds of
things that would have all remained you
can't wish any of that away
but you can make the process of working
together
uh way better and we just i just i as a
leader i just wasn't disciplined enough
to make that happen
and
you know we did a much better job of it
collectively with the second version
now obviously i i can assume that you
know
growing so quickly the team both in the
first team in in the first version but
then continuing with it with a great
with a big team in the second version
you have to go from really
detail-oriented management to then
extremely high level and overlooking a
grand strategy right
how does that work from a leadership
perspective how how are you able to
navigate through these difficult
transitions
well the best part for me is that i was
more a natural leader in the second
phase than i was in the first phase
i have this leadership theory that i
call explorers pioneers and settlers
and there's some people who are explorer
leaders and they're just
out to find things
and they're really good at that and then
there's other people who are pioneers
who once something's been discovered
they're great at creating it into
something steve jobs was a pioneer right
i mean he was just really great at
creating things and bill gates in many
respects was a pioneer
and then there are settlers and these
are people which i say proudly i'm a
settler
i'm about scaling things
yeah and
so once we got to the second version we
were already finding things
and my skill set was to scale it
how do we take that team and super size
it how do we make the business
significantly bigger how do we drive
profitability
um and so i in many respects i was the
wrong leader for the first version
because i'm not a pioneer nor am i an
explorer and i was the right leader for
the second version and you know that's
just something you figure out after the
fact i suppose
well thank you for
you know making my life better through
the xbox i obviously
enjoyed a lot and and
and and so i can only imagine you know
the trying to cope with this idea of of
the impact that that you had in in
leading this team and building this
console and and thinking you know about
you know a worldwide phenomena of of
gaming and entertainment in a different
way
and i'm really curious about this
transition to being a novelist and civic
engineer so retiring from microsoft at
and after
you know doing so much and working with
some of the smartest people in the world
turning to
writing and turning turning to
storytelling what what is that for you
well
i the first thing i turned to was
i'm going from being a person who's
trying to maximize the business to being
a person who's trying to help make
things better around him on a full-time
basis and so that meant getting involved
with a number of non-profits
and doing those things but i also found
that for my own personal
fulfillment
i needed a creative outlet i needed to
explore a side of my
life that you know i just hadn't been
able to do when i was working 100 you
know hours at microsoft right i mean you
just you don't have the time to do that
so i wrote a non-fiction book called
xbox revisited which is a business
strategy book about that 3p framework
that we talked about right really nice
book very good business strategy book
loved writing it
and when it came time to write a second
book i said no i'm not going to do
non-fiction i want to do fiction i want
to challenge myself to learn about
character development and dialogue and
scene description plot and because i
love thrillers i'm going to write a
thriller
and
i'm not going to a camp i'm not going to
let anybody teach me i'm just going to
start and wow in the fall of 2016
i started
and it and this is the book that is
coming out literally in
in a week right
that's correct yeah the book comes out
on october 12th it's called the wilkes
insurrection
it's um a contemporary thriller it's
about what's going on in our world today
um and it has all the the elements of
plot twists and fast pace that a
thriller you'd expect
and you know i think has a level of uh
creativity and innovation in it um that
i'm actually really proud of i i'm
excited to have people read it
so four years later or five years later
almost right it was
for writing this book and putting it out
does it feel anywhere the same as the
release of
you know of either of the xbox versions
or is this completely different
well it's
it has some elements of the same and
there's some elements that are different
like right xbox was at a scale
and and my job was managing a big team
and and trying to help the whole team
get that done
um this is different i mean i'm the
chief marketing officer i'm the chief
development officer yes you know i'm i'm
the part of the product
that part is very different what's
what's the theme
is that anticipation of not knowing how
people are gonna react right are people
gonna love what you created
or are they not gonna love what you
created
and you know that is a fascinating
process and you know where i'm just now
we're just now starting to get early
reviews of wilkes insurrection
thankfully people are really liking it
so i'm i'm happy about that but that
tension is there and it was there with
xbox boy you know
two months before we launched we weren't
sure a that we were going to finish and
b that anybody was going to like the
result
and it turned out halo was incredible
and uh
you know so i that yeah
that it has in common for sure
i i a hundred percent a bit of a
personal question
how did you
reach how did you reach this conviction
that this is something that you want to
do so i think one of the things that
fascinated me about leaders
is sometimes their ability to distill
their you know intrinsic motivation and
what they who they really are
and verily intentionally pursuing that
now
you were you know in the business world
president at within microsoft you were
you know writing a non-fiction book on
strategy from stanford business school
earlier on
what
how do you get to a point where you say
you know what
now i'm gonna do something for me
something that is not as business
oriented i'm gonna write a thriller how
does that happen
well for me i think it stems from a one
very important fundamental belief
which i think the life journey we're on
is about continuously trying to learn
and continuing continuously trying to
explore new talents new skills i never
use the word retired ever
i it's just not a word that's in my
vocabulary i say i i left microsoft and
but i don't say i retired
um and and i'm i still work hard i'm i'm
a really hard worker i enjoy working so
um
you know for me the book had two
purposes one was it was an amazing
learning process
and two
you know as you if you have a chance to
read it and as others have a chance to
read it you'll discover that it's not
actually that far away from some of the
civic things that i talk about and some
of the other work that i do
and
it's a
hardcore contemporary thriller
and i hope when you're finished with it
you also say oh i learned something
along the way too
that to me is uh is the ultimate
challenge and was what i set out to to
try to to achieve
i love it robbie take me back to your
childhood
early on elementary school middle school
pre xbox free microsoft pre-stanford
what are you excited what what
fascinates you what sparks your
curiosity as a kid
uh the things i i think i
yeah i i would
the things that fascinated me were
twofold
one i positively loved to read
and i read a lot
um i read every hearty boys book there
was like 56 of them at the time
um i read um in middle school a lot
about world war ii in history i love
history
and so i have continued that passion for
history and and reading and
learning um so that's one thing and the
second thing i loved
is i loved any form of sports
and so i played all sports
um and you know so i had sort of these
two sides i had this sort of you know
sit and read for three hours
and then you know go play competitive
tennis which you know i ended up playing
tennis in college right you know so
those two things have always been kind
of a part of my life and it started when
i was super young
i love it and if you had to look today
at what is really guiding your
inspiration through either the civic
engineering the work that you do as a
novelist the storytelling what what what
is really you know a a north star of
inspiration for you
i the thing that for me is inspirational
is actually observing others who are
able to make a difference
you know i do a lot of work with an
organization called boys and girls clubs
of america which is an amazing
organization serves about four million
kids in the country
mostly kids who who don't have any a
place to go
and what inspires me is watching not
only the amazing things that the kids do
and the kids are
truly pretty pretty impressive
but the staff people who enable that to
happen and the volunteer hours that go
into making that happen
is
it's awesome
it's awesome and it you know it makes me
say hey i gotta do more i watch what the
outcome of that work and i watch what
these people do who
don't get paid as much money as they
probably deserve and yet they're so
passionate about the cars that to me is
um
to your word it's inspirational
i love it
and if you had to choose a few words
that you would use to define yourself
oh they be
um
i wouldn't be truthful if i didn't use
the word competitive
um i am a really really competitive
person so i
i try to hide that as best i can but i'd
be lying
so that's the first one the second thing
is
i've discovered over time that my brain
works in a in a strategic way
um and when i'm faced with a problem i'm
my first approach is to step back and
try to think okay what's the strategy
that we have to do which is ironic
because i did that first xbox without
any strategy and i think somehow that
has deeped into my
my dna
and the third thing i'll say is i'm
committed
i i don't do things sort of half-assed
that's just not in my nature
and so when i do something it's like
this book you know if i'm going to write
a book i'm in and and i got to make it
happen
amazing i love it robbie thank you so so
much this was inspiring this was
so interesting and i can't wait to
obviously read the book and to share
this episode um i love the journey i
love the insights i love the
authenticity and the honesty and i
really appreciate it and thank you for
everything stay safe and stay healthy
hey youtube thanks michael thank you
robbie take care